Election Day is is is coming up it's
coming up tomorrow in fact in case you
didn't know and I do have just one thing
I would like to remind you of as you
head into the polls one relevant piece
of history ancient history okay
admittedly this was a long long time ago
that's why I feel like I have to remind
you of it but this goes all the way back
way way way way back to the beginning of
October try to bring your mind back to
the beginning of October and recall the
orchestrated smear campaign of Justice
Cavanaugh now you may have noticed as we
head into the election what Democrats
have been saying about Cavanaugh
especially ever since his confirmation
notice the things that they've been
saying about him that is specifically it
should be easy to remember what they've
been saying because they've said nothing
they aren't talking about him anymore
they don't bring him up have you noticed
that and and that's weird isn't it
because according to them according to
them he's a he's a rapist
according to then Republicans put a
rapist on the bench so isn't it weird
that they haven't been citing that fact
repeatedly constantly on the campaign
trail they talked about it while the
confirmation process was going on but as
soon as he's confirmed they stopped
talking about you think it would be
almost the opposite like Republicans
have now actually put this guy on the
bench he's a rapist according to them
yet they're not talking about that well
I think we know why and I think we know
why they stopped talking about it and we
can actually there was a report a full
report released by the Senate Judiciary
Committee after they conducted their you
finished up their investigation and
they're on on on the whole Cavanaugh
debacle and they just released this
report over the weekend it's 400 pages
long but here's what it says in part let
me just
this is how they kind of summarize it it
says after an extensive investigation
that included the thorough review of all
potentially credible evidence submitted
and interviews of more than 40
individuals with information relating to
the allegations including classmates and
Friends of all those involved committee
investigators found no witnesses who
could provide any verifiable evidence to
support any of the allegations brought
against justice Cavanaugh in other words
following the separate and extensive
investigations by both the committee and
the FBI there was no evidence of
substitutes of some substantiate any of
the claims of sexual assault made
against justice Cavanaugh what's more
the committee is also calling for
charges against Julie sweat Nix she's
the woman who alleged all those gang
rapes if you recall there is shockingly
reason to believe that she's a perjuring
liar and a fraud along with her along
with her pseudo lawyer avenatti so you
know it's interesting we haven't heard
anything from sweat Nick either after
the sense the confirmation
according to her judge justice Kavanagh
is a is a serial gang rapists but she
suddenly has gone silent
haven't heard anything from her have you
noticed that well I think we know why
and the committee also is calling for
charges against another woman who now
admits to making up allegations against
Kavanaugh and the committee is also
investigating Monica McClain who's the
woman the former FBI agent who allegedly
tried to encourage a witness to change
her story so that it would support
Christian Ford's story on top of all
that the report details in interview
that the committee conducted with
another man who says that he had an
encounter at the time in question in the
area in question in a bedroom with a
girl who had a one-piece bathing suit on
under her clothes and the encounter was
with
what in a girl who looked a lot like
Christine Ford looked at that time
according to the pictures that he's seen
and that encounter was was ended when
another guy jumped on top of them so
there was another guy in the room and it
ended when someone jumped on top
he says the encounter was consensual
though but there's every reason to
suspect that this may in fact be the
encounter that Ford was talking about
which would mean that she was wrong not
only about the person who she had this
encounter with but she was wrong about
whether or not it was consensual which
would mean that this was of course on
her part would have had to have been
more than just a lapsed memory situation
this you know this would be in that case
just just a lie and a fraud on her part
and it actually would kind of make sense
you know because although her story was
strangely vague in it was vague
especially about details that that you
wouldn't think she would be vague about
about things that you'd think she would
remember so it was vague in those parts
but then there were those those those
few things that she was very detailed
about and and very descriptive about and
she was able when talking about the
story to conjure up some emotion about
it
so if she took something that actually
happened and just kind of trance played
in Kavanaugh into it and then changed
some of the details to make it
non-consensual it was consensual then
that would kind of explain how she was
able to be detailed about certain things
but not others and and all that so it's
clear why the Democrats have stopped
talking about this the truth is the
truth is coming out it has come out and
it is completely utterly damning to
everyone involved in the attack on
Cavanaugh the man is being completely
vindicated in remarkable ways really
because it's actually pretty impressive
when you think about it that there could
be so much evidence proving his
innocence you know in relation to a
made-up crime than thirty five years ago
if an innocent man is accused of doing
something three decades ago the most he
could usually hope to find to
to support his side to prove his
innocence is a lack of evidence on the
other side so if you're accused of doing
something 30 years ago in most cases the
most you could hope for is that the
other side just has no evidence because
35 from 35 years ago you're not gonna be
able to present your own evidence
proving that you were innocent but
remarkably Cavanaugh Cavanaugh has that
you know he has the lack of evidence
against him but he also has a ton of
evidence actively vindicating him
evidence like another man coming forward
and saying no it was me evidence like
the denials of all the alleged witnesses
evidence like recanted statements from
accusers evidence like his calendar
showing what all the played things that
he did during the the summer in question
so it's just overwhelming but Democrats
knew that this would happen okay the
gambit for them was very simple for them
it was throw everything at Cavanaugh no
matter how absurd and unsubstantiated
destroy him keep him off the court and
then and then weeks later when the truth
comes out and they knew that it would
come out but then they could just rely
on the media to ignore it and bury it
all they cared about was let's just keep
him off the court now I'll destroy him
and then when the truth comes out three
four weeks from now it's not gonna
matter anymore
the damage will be done media won't
report it nobody will hear about it
and they were right about that the media
of course is ignoring this but sadly for
the Democrats the the gambit didn't work
out because Cavanaugh was on the court
the only question now is whether the
voters will make Democrats pay for this
smear campaign and I really hope they do
you know I think of course I'm biased
but I think there are many reasons not
to vote for Democrats but even if you
know if you're someone who's on the
fence politically or ideologically this
should definitely be enough to push you
if not towards voting for Republicans at
least staying home and not voting for
Democrats when when
you see what they did I mean this is
this is as I said throughout the entire
thing this is one of the most brazen
smear campaigns and some of the most
brazen dishonesty that we've ever seen
from politicians especially when you
think about it's not just one politician
it was many of them it was the Democrat
Party together decide him to engage in
this in this campaign of destruction and
lies and slander they just they can they
have to be punished for that for the
sake of common decency for the sake of
preserving in whatever extent we still
can the integrity of our political
process we just they have to be punished
for that so please keep that in mind as
you head to the polls okay moving on I
want to touch briefly on on something
Pete Davidson is a comedian on SNL maybe
you heard about this over the weekend he
made a bad and stupid joke very bad very
stupid about a GOP GOP congressional
candidate named Dan Crenshaw and
Crenshaw is a veteran who lost an eye
while fighting overseas so he wears an
eyepatch now and Davidson joked that
Crenshaw looks like he said it looks
like the hit man in a porno which in my
innocence and naivete I didn't even
realize that was a category of person
that you would find in a porno a hit man
but leave that aside nevertheless it was
as I said a stupid and bad joke and
offensive as he was obviously mocking
someone who's suffering a disability
from from from war and to mock someone
with a disability at all is bad to mock
their disability when they when they
when they got it fighting for the
country just makes it all the more worse
but it was a joke we can say it was a
joke from a comedian bad stupid
offensive but a joke
yes and conservatives are usually the
first ones to say that listen you know
it's you got to give comedians leeway
here that you know we can't get overly
sensitive about jokes the comedians tell
even when they're bad stupid and
offensive yet many conservatives reacted
to this joke with immense outrage and
almost immediately there was a campaign
being organized to to put pressure on
NBC's advertisers and there were people
calling for boycotts and people calling
for David said to be fired and on and on
and on now mr. krenshaw himself to his
credit did not engage in this and I
think this is really impressive you know
he took it in stride basically and and
in fact he decried the culture of
outrage when we demand apologies and he
said he's not gonna do that he thinks
it's silly the demand apologies and that
that's great he did say that it was an
unfunny joke is a bad joke and it's not
okay to make fun of wounded warriors but
he didn't call for a boycott he didn't
demand an apology as I said to his
credit but a lot of people did a lot of
conservatives did demand boycotts and
firings and all the rest of it and we
know of course that if the person who
made the offensive remark about wounded
warriors was himself a Republican most
of these Republicans would not be
reacting this way and you know how I
know that because President Trump
famously mocked a disabled War veteran
and P o w9 John McCain not only mocked
him but mocked him for being a peel w
and most of the people outraged by a
comedians joke actually defended the
comment from Trump when you could easily
make the case that the comment from
Trump was ten times worse because jumps
not a comedian he's a presidential
candidate this was a comedian which is
just it's such a blatant double standard
that III I would be shocked by it if I
wasn't so jaded and cynical and
completely used to double standards but
the people in gate you know the people
that defended Trump's common yet are
calling for boycotts
because of this they must know that
they're being hypocrites like you you
must look in the mirror and say to
yourself I am being a total hypocrite
and I know it and we can't become
comfortable with hypocrisy look here's
my point
first of all there used to be a time not
not too long ago when comedians would
make outrageously offensive jokes
constantly jokes jokes that would be
several orders of magnitude worse than
what Pete did it's it said in fact you
don't even have to go back that far
there was a there was a there was a
Comedy Central Roast I forget who was
being roasted it was only a couple of
years ago and and Davidson himself Pete
Davidson was at them at the roast and
other comedians were mocking him because
his dad died on 9/11 they were not only
making 9/11 jokes but they were making
9/11 jokes about Pete Davidson's dad who
died
now speaking of 9/11 and offensive jokes
Gilbert Godfried who is known for being
outrageous and making jokes about about
the most horrible kinds of things
actually made a 9/11 joke in New York
like two weeks after the attack he was
in New York and he made a joke as far as
whole audience and of course he was
booed off the stage but this is the kind
of stuff that comedians used to do
someone reminded me yesterday of and I
remember I remember seeing this what it
happened in 2005 or 2006 Norma Donald
went on The Daily Show only a few days
after Steve Irwin died and he proceeded
to joke about it for five minutes he
went into this extended riff where he
was imagining how disappointed the
crocodiles must have been that a
stingray killed Steve Irwin and one of
them was enabled in fact he's they were
disappointed that a fruity fish killed
Steve Irwin instead of one of them
I mean these days even just use the word
fruity in that context would probably
get him boycotted but it speaks say
nothing of the fact that he was making
fun of this guy who just died like two
days before and those are just a couple
of recent examples though you go back
decades go back to Richard Pryor George
Carlin Don Rickles I mean all those guys
and you find comedians making absolutely
outrageous jokes about really dark
subject matter and sometimes the jokes
aren't funny like Davidson joke was not
funny sometimes sometimes they're
horrible but you can't help but laugh
sometimes they really do cross a line
and they're unfunny Davidson's joke
crossed a line it was unfunny
I think the jokes directed at him about
his dad dying the 911 those are not
funny and they cross the line but but we
have to ask ourselves would we rather
live in a world where offensive
comedians can be offensive without it
turning into a boycott or do we like
living in this world where every
outrageous joke becomes its own news
cycle maybe another way of putting it is
this what was actually wrong with the
original way of doing things was anyone
being harmed by these jokes
I mean if you if you lived through the
dark times of say the 90s when comedians
would make horrible jokes all the time
constantly about all kinds of things and
nobody batted an eye
but if you could go back on a time
machine to the night tonight 90s would
you look around and say to yourself wow
you know the fact that comedians can
make offensive jokes that's a big
problem we have to do you know this is
this is this is a problem it is our new
approach our readiness to be offended by
any joke is that solving some kind of
problem what problem was solved by this
I don't think it is I think it's just
and it becomes all the way you know I
think people get this wrong because
people say well we were so sensitive
these days we're so and that is part of
it I mean we are sensitive
too sensitive but it's even worse than
that because I think our sensitivity is
often performative its theatrical it's
not really sensitivity that's ruining
comedy it's partisanship partisanship on
the part of the comedians who who are
selective these days and they're targets
based on politics and we all know how
comedians you know when we talk about
what's killing comedy we have to keep in
mind that many of these comedians
themselves killed comedy by the fact
that even political satirist people that
you know the SNL is supposed to be
political satire but for eight years
they had no jokes to make about the
president which which was a which was a
death blow to comedy in and of itself so
there's partisanship on the part of the
comedians and then partisanship on the
part of the public where we're just
looking for any opportunity any ammo we
can find to throw at the other side and
so we look at comedy through that lens
it's not just that comedians themselves
are presenting the comedy through a
partisan lens they are doing that but we
also are perceiving the comedy through a
partisan lens and deciding what we think
is funny and what we think is offensive
based on our partisanship and that's
just I mean it's it's fatal to comedy
first of all and that's kind of a
tragedy because who I mean who wants to
live in a world without comedy I think
that's one of the four human beings I
feel like that's an essential ingredient
to living a human life you need you need
you need humor right you need to be able
to laugh and I would say it's better to
err on the side of laughing at too many
things than not being able to laugh at
anything
because there's always some partisan
snowflake ready to get offended
and again this is not I'm not defending
the joke was a horrible stupid unfunny
joke so you know we can all say that
it's okay to point that out even but
what I'm talking about is the boycotts
and firing them and let's me
into a news cycle that's what I'm
talking about that's the problem
I think our reaction to those kind of
jokes should be exactly the reaction
that Crenshaw himself had which was so
it's a funny on stupid joke now I'm
moving on with my life or unfunny stupid
joke I meant to say okay finally one
more subject here that want to talk
about there was a teacher by the name of
Marston Reilly in Los Angeles who was
arrested for child abuse I think was
last week after punching one of his
students and the let me see here the
incident was was caught on camera and so
you see the fourteen-year-old kid
berating the teacher cussing him out
taunting him refusing to to leave the
classroom and finally he throws a
basketball at the teacher and then
really gets in his face and at which
point Riley punches the kid in a scuffle
ensues and Riley punches him several
more times and now Riley the teacher is
being charged with a crime and will
probably lose his job
now you know if you're familiar with me
at all you know that I am NOT a defender
of the public school system and I am not
at all hesitant to criticize teachers I
do it frequently but I think it's absurd
to charge this man with a crime a child
abuse come on and I don't think he
should be fired I have no problem saying
that this young punk got exactly what he
needed and deserved I have no doubt that
a beat-down from the teacher may be them
this you know I mean I don't know we
can't make assumptions based on one
video but this does not seem like the
sort of kid who's really getting a lot
out of school right and so this may end
up being the most important educational
moment of his life up to this point it
also doesn't seem like the kind of kid
who's getting a lot of education at home
so this may this really may be the most
important lesson he ever got and it
didn't come in a book it came with a
punch to the face now yeah obviously the
teacher
cannot outright condone a teacher
punching a student even if the student
was cussing him out and throwing objects
at him so what I think the school should
do is they should suspend the teacher
with pay for like a week and then have
them come back and get back to his job
and they should expel the student expel
the student give the teacher a you know
a a paid one-week vacation while they
investigate and then have them come back
in and you know what I think even the
teacher should probably throw them a
nice little part little private party in
the faculty lounge bring cupcakes and
that kind of thing not in front of
everybody you know I'm not saying we
throw him a party in the auditorium I
mean I that would be kind of nice also
but of course I know that won't happen I
just I have a lot of sympathy for the
teacher in the situation and absolutely
none for the kid none and I think it's
hard for some people to concept
conceptualize just what teachers in
certain districts deal with now it's not
like this in every school but in some
schools there are students who are just
absurdly abusive to the teachers
completely uncontrollable no respect for
authority at all I mean really no
respect they none there are teachers who
are verbally abused and berated and
sometimes physically abused constantly
every day and this is not how it should
be this is not this is not normal
this is not what an educational
environment is supposed to be like and I
think that we should tolerate our
teachers being human on occasion I'll
tell you this I would not be able to
deal with that kind of behavior every
day without smacking somebody in the
face I wouldn't be able to do it and let
me also say that this is not child abuse
okay the moment that a teenager starts
acting this way towards an adult towards
a grown man he is not a child anymore he
clearly wants to be a man and he wants
to play a man's game and he wants to man
up and be a tough guy so I say let him
face the consequences
child abuse oh the poor child was abused
no the porch
I wanted to be a man and he was treated
like one and maybe he learned his lesson
the idea that a teenager that a teenage
delinquent is some kind of pure innocent
helpless child is absurd
and I really think in these kinds of
situations we have to we have to
consider the message now again I'm not
suggesting that there be a new policy at
the school saying you know they put it
in the handbook that if a kid gets out
of line the teachers a lot of punch him
in the face you know I think there could
be some violet possibly some value to a
system like that but I could get chaotic
so I'm not talking about a change in
policy I'm talking about the school
being very very lenient in their
discipline of the teacher and very very
strict in their discipline of the
student in this case and I'll tell you
why because well number one like I said
we have to allow for a teacher to be a
human being and react like a human being
and he reacted a way that especially if
you're dealing with this every day I
mean eventually you just get worn down
you can't deal with this every single
day but we also have to think about the
message so if the teacher is fired
what's the message the message is that
delinquent kids can act like animals
without any consequences or without any
immediate consequences I should say the
message is that kids can abuse teachers
and they will never have to worry about
their own safety they will never have to
worry about any sort of retaliation they
can act however they want towards adults
and the adults will never defend
themselves is that really the right
message do you think that that doesn't
embolden the delinquents do you think
they don't realize that teachers are
powerless and then exploit that
situation because I'll tell you they do
this to teach the students in these
schools they realize that they can get a
teacher's face they can even physically
abuse a teacher and the teacher cannot
do anything without having to worry
about going to jail and being fired they
real
that and they exploit it every day
constantly they are exploiting that fact
so my point is maybe a student should
have to worry that his lip will get
busted if you get to the teachers face
what what's the downside to it to it to
a student having to worry about that are
we I mean really what's the downside
what's the downside to a student having
to think to himself hmm you know if I
act like a total animal to this grown
man and I get in his face and I her load
an object at him he might punch me in
the face what's the downside what are we
worried so he worried that the poor the
poor helpless child may be traumatized
by that by that real is it he may feel
unsafe he'll feel unsafe in school well
he should feel unsafe when he's acting
like that that's the point there's
there's a limit about you know there's a
limit on human actions and if you if you
act outside the that limit you should
have to feel unsafe you should have to
think to yourself you know what if I
keep carrying on this way I might get
punched in the face I think that is a
good calculation for a person to have to
make including kids now obviously it's
different if we're talking about a
five-year-old it's totally different
situation but 14 15 year old 15 years
old I'm sorry it you know I think now
you you've reached an age where if you
want to puff up your chest and act like
a man you might be treated like one
and you can't complain about it the
school issued a statement and from the
statement it seems like they're
definitely going in the wrong direction
with this the statement is we are
extremely disturbed by the reports of
the events that occurred at the Maywood
Academy High School we take this matter
very seriously and do not condone
violence or intolerance of any kind Los
Angeles Unified is cooperating with law
enforcement crisis counselors and
additional school police patrols will be
at school on Monday to support our
students and staff we
condone intolerance really it's so
intolerance yeah well you should have
condoned that that so there should be
intolerance to that sort of behavior
what are you talking about so their
problem with what the teacher did was
not only was it violent but it was
intolerant of course it's intolerant the
kid is acting in a completely
intolerable way so he should meet
intolerance crisis counselors I mean
come on this this is exactly the wrong
I'm telling you I know schools feel like
they have to react this way but you
react this way all you're doing you may
as well write in a written invitation to
every delinquent at the school saying
please act like even worse animals than
you've already been acting here you go
here's an invitation please go and get
in your teachers face and taunt and
berate him and you know please RSVP by
by noon to let us know if you you may as
well you may as well hand out
invitations at that point because that's
how the kids take it whereas if we could
just use a little bit of common human
sense and sense and say you know what we
cannot officially condone the teacher be
you know delivering a physical beatdown
to a student but the kid definitely
deserved it this is a good teacher by
all accounts good man and he just lost
his cool go settle down little paid
vacation we'll call it an in that will
call it discipline it's not really
you'll come back in a week and and
everything will be fine and that kid is
gonna be out of the school so then that
the students have to say to themselves
you know what if I act that way to a
teacher not only man might might I get
my nose broken but I'm gonna get
expelled and that teacher is gonna get
to stay what's wrong with that isn't
that exactly the message that the
students should should hear unless you
want
chaos in the schools which is exactly
what you get
many of these could in many of these
schools it's not an exaggeration to say
there is just total chaos because when
the kids don't respect the adults and
they have no reason to respect them and
the adults have their hands tied behind
their back it's just kids are gonna
exploit that and so I think we have to
rethink our approach in those cases all
right we'll leave it there big day
tomorrow
voting please keep in mind what we
discussed at the beginning of the show
and I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed